hallo mein name ist luca und meine
lieben zuschauer gestern habe ich hier
auf meinem kanal einen blog hochgeladen
in dem ich in münchen bei gustav augusto
tausende pizzen probiert haben um
herauszufinden was auf der lu kapitza
drei eventuell viel zutaten sein könnten
[Applaus]
das video ging auf jeden fall mega durch
die decke und hat mittlerweile schon
irgendwie 5 6000 kommentare darunter
stehen und ich wollte im heutigen video
einfach mal so ein bisschen auf ein paar
fragen kommentare und allgemeinen
reaktionen von euch auf di luca pizza 3
1 gegen los geht
trinkspiele idee jedes mal trinken wenn
luca gustavo musst du sagt hey ich hab
dann nicht oft gustavo gustavo ist ja
schon auf mich dann ich glaube es wird
nicht vertrug form oder wie man das
schreibt daran aber ich würde es mega
feiern wenn di luca pizza drei
vegetarisch wäre und mit viel käse ich
lebe käse einfach ich kann mir auf jeden
fall zu beiden sachen sagen ja die pizza
wird definitiv vegetarisch sein und es
wird auch auf jeden fall käse auf der
pizza sein wie viele pfützen wird luca
noch raushauen 1 like gleich eine pizza
will ich mal sehen wie viele leute
kommen da hat ja ich ändere dann einfach
komplett deutschland gewesen luca
eröffne eine eigene pizzeria dann
könntest du neben youtube noch bisher
geld verdienen ich glaube das ist keine
gute idee wenn ich eine eigene pizzeria
eröffnen würde dann würde ich selbst du
die ganze zeit zu essen und dann würde
ich dick werden und ich weiß nicht wie
es euch dabei geht aber wenn mir ist es
auch so ich konnte auch nie koch werden
weil immer wenn ich irgendwas richtig
geiles koche dann will ich dass die dana
person immer wieder selbst essen also ja
danke für den kommentar ich glaube das
wird nicht passiert auf dem loser pizza
wird bestimmt
ja toastbrot legen oder di luca pizza
drei wirte trost besser sein heil ganz
kurze info jedem reingeschoben von mir
im schnitt gerade an ihr seht die ganze
zeit hier oben werde video eingeblendet
das war auch gestern meinen blogs oder
habe ich ein paar leute gefragt hey
warum steht da die ganze zeit werden sie
dürfen dafür bezahle dagegen wie sowas
nähe ich werde nicht proaktiv für dieses
video dafür dass letzten video bezahlt
sondern es geht einfach um mein produkt
um di luca pizza 3 und von daher möchte
ich auf der sicheren seite seien einfach
komplett werbevideo reinzuschreiben aber
hier ist nichts irgendwie verdient keine
ahnung was es geht einfach mit lukas 23
und deswegen wie der werbe wie gehört
geht weil das zugfahren ist auch viel
umweltfreundlicher als inlandsflüge das
stimmt definitiv und mir selbst ist
einfach auf der rückfahrt von münchen
nach köln mit der bahn aufgefallen dass
es einfach auch viel viel entspannter
als all zu fliegen es ist viel
stressfreier man kann das schön was
essen dann kann ein paar serien gucken
man kann am handy sein die cetera pp das
ist einfach viel viel besser als gegen
finde ich auch das sollte jetzt gar
nicht groß werbung für die öbb seien
oder irgendwie sonst war es aber ich
finde wir müssen wirklich mal langsam
sondern bisschen den umweltschutz mehr
in unseren köpfen verankern und von
daher habe ich mir selbst auch einfach
das ziel gesetzt innerhalb von
deutschland nur noch bahn zu fahren und
natürlich klar kann man jetzt sagen ey
luca dann steckst du hast im ausland
sitzen da trotzdem anstatt 180 979 leute
in der flug geht trotzdem habe ich finde
man muss ja mal anfang klimaschutz bin
ich wieder lachen zu sehen mach weiter
so viel talk dass man kann es nicht in
worte fassen wie ein so ein kleiner
kommentar schon so voller glücksgefühle
erfüllt ich weiß ihr versteht was ich
genau meine aber gerade wenn man halt so
viele kommentare liest und alle handeln
wie davon darf man davon bla bla bla bla
bla und beziehen sich mal welcher auf
die eigene person und sagen hey das ist
echt cool dass du glücklich bist mach
weiter so und so das freut einen
wirklich und ich glaube ich sagt viel zu
wenig danke dafür also danke schön und
auch danke für euer allgemeines feedback
unter dem pizza videos hat mich so
überrascht wie viele positive
rückmeldungen bekommen die wird
wahrscheinlich auch wieder fünf bis
sechs euro passten also fünf bis sechs
euro wie die luca pizza 3 definitiv
nicht kosten aber was ihr euch definitiv
sagen muss man auch sagen möchte ist
dass sie selbstverständlich wieder
teurer wird als beispielsweise eine
pizza von dr
wagner aber da kennt ihr auch meine
einstellung ich verkaufe lieber ein
produkt was ein paar euros teurer ist
als ein produkt mit dem ich nicht 100
prozent zufrieden bin und dann nehmen
wir lieber regionale zutaten und alles
mögliche als dass ich sage kommt dann
drückt man den preis noch ein bisschen
mehr und machen dann hier ein
schlechteres mail und keine ahnung was
er wann kommt die neue luca petra viele
liebe grüße nach grün also gestrigen
wieder euch ja bereits ins auto
geschrieben dass di luca pizza 3 ab
november diesen jahres in den supermarkt
filialen vorhanden sein wird und dabei
bleibt es auch
also dieses jahr im november
wahrscheinlich mitte ende kommt di luca
pizza 3 raus ja geil
ich hoffe dass das pizza
sehr lecker schmeckt ich liebe pizza als
wir haben noch keine 100 prozent finale
luca pizza drei gegessen aber wir wissen
auf jeden fall welche zutaten drauf
kommen und diese pizza hut allen zehn
leute mit dem wir in münchen waren auf
jeden fall mega mega gut geschmeckt
schlussendlich ist es aber
geschmackssache und ich kann jetzt nicht
versprechen dass es jedem schmecken wird
aber ich glaube dass sie auf jeden fall
mehr leuten gefallen während mehr leute
werden sie essen können als luca pizza
zwei lager wird dein metall in dpa afx
die ganzen plastik willst du bei der
luca pizza 2000 zwischenzeitig ganz
lustig ich musste selbst manchmal echt
krass lachen weil ein paar kommentare
aber bei der duh kapitza 38 mir auf
jeden fall kraft penibel darauf dass ich
so etwas definitiv nicht wiederholen
wird
also ich glaube ihr habt ja im gestrigen
blog auch gesehen was das jetzt für
kranke sicherheitsbestimmungen da sind
die hygienevorschriften und vor allem
hofft dass die ganze pizzen noch mal
durch ein röntgengerät laufen
da wird noch mal mit einem x-ray scanner
geguckt ob da wirklich die pizza oder
prozent in ordnung ist und das hat auch
kein anderer als tiefkühlpizzen
herstellungs- unternehmen in deutschland
also der kamera weg ich mal kurz was du
kannst du mal einen online shop für
pizza aufmachen an sich eigentlich gar
keine so schlechte idee also ich glaube
es wird auf jeden fall ganz gut laufen
das ding ist aber auf jeden fall dass es
luca pizza drei wahrscheinlich auch
wieder im rewe lieferservice geben wird
also in einigen städten in deutschland
kann man sich ja bei rewe online die
produkte bestellen die man kaufen möchte
und da wird man sich dann denke ich auch
wieder luca pizza 3 bestellen können ehe
die pizza ist mit schweinefleisch ich
verspreche dir himmel hoch und heilig
dass auf der pizza kein schweinefleisch
sein wird warum heißt eigentlich pizza
pizza
haben
kann
oslo kafitz 23 kann alles drauf aber
nicht salon oder ananas die traurige
sache ist halt dass man es leider nie
allen leuten recht machen kann also wenn
der eine sagt hey ich will unbedingt
einer dass aufnahmen feiert und das auf
der pizza so übertrieben dann sagen aber
99 wiederum neben anderen das find ich
selbst nicht sogar da sagt der andere
wieder ja ok aber da muss unbedingt das
brauche dann sagen andere leute wieder
dann würde ich die pizza nicht kaufen
aber ich glaube wirklich dass wir mit
der luca pizza 3 und dem rezept dass wir
jetzt aus entwickelt aus gerät aus
ich glaube dass di luca bis drei fast
allen sehr gut schmecken wird und auf
die frage zurückzukommen nein es kommt
keine salami und auch keine an astra
kommt in die pizza wie der aktivkohle
auf die frage habe ich leider vergessen
im video einzugehen von daher mache ich
das jetzt kurz hier im nachhinein die
pizza wird keine aktivkohle beinhalten
der teig wird auch nicht schwarz auch
nicht grün oder bunt was auch wieder in
den kommentaren dachten der teig wird
komplett normal sein es wird ein ganz
normaler pizzateig sein und es wird
keine aktivkohle drin sein oder
irgendetwas anderes attestiert und menge
käse drauf sein so viel kann ich schon
mal sagen kann dass bt die pizza auch in
österreich geben also di luca pizza 3
wird es auf jeden fall flächendeckend in
deutschland geben und wir sprechen
mittlerweile auch mit anderen supermarkt
filialen und ketten als nur mit rewe und
edeka und wir sprechen beispielsweise
auch mit österreich aber schlussendlich
ist es so dass wir die luca pizza drei
wirklich jedem anbieten wollen und wir
bieten di luca pizza 3 auf jedem anders
als jeder markt hat die chance wenn sie
sagen ey wir wollen den cup ist a 3 bei
uns drin haben dann haben sie die chance
sie zu bekommen dass wir die beliefern
aber schlussendlich ist halt der markt
derjenige der entscheidet ob es bei ihm
die duh kapitza 3 geben wird oder nicht
von daher kann ich diese frage noch
nicht viel viel viel filiale final
beantworten bin nicht blöd alter wird es
die lokale 23 nur für einen bestimmten
zeitraum geben wenn nichts dazwischen
kommt oder für unbestimmte zeit was ich
dir dazu auf jeden fall sagen kann ist
dass es die lupe 23 auf jeden fall in
der größeren ausführung geben wird als
beispielsweise in lucka pizza 1 von der
es ja nur 100000 stück gab oder di luca
pizza zwei von der es nur
eine million stück gab es wird auf jeden
fall mehr davon geben aber muss ich ganz
ehrlich sein wenn wir irgendwann merken
haye
die leute essen di luca pizza 3 nicht
mehr und keine ahnung was dann macht es
natürlich keinen sinn wenn wir davon
noch ganz viele produzieren und die
werden alle nicht gegessen also es wird
sie auf jeden fall in großer ausführung
geben aber ob es die jetzt für die
nächsten 30 jahre geben wird das wage
ich zu bezweifeln beste pizza mit sauce
hollandaise brokkoli und zuzug ja ich
glaube an der stelle soll sich das
heutige video dann auch mal beenden ich
hoffe auf jeden fall dass sich einige
eurer fragen auf jeden fall gut
beantworten konnte und auf eure
kommentare gut reagieren konnte falls
euch das video hier gefallen da will ich
mich sehr darüber einen daumen hoch von
euch unter dem video hier freuen und
schreiben in die kommentare
immer noch was ihr denkt was oft di luca
pizza 3 drauf kommen wir denn unter dem
gestrigen video von 5600 kommentaren
hatte keiner es komplett richtig was auf
der pizza sein wird abonniert gern kurz
bloß unter dem video main kanal falls
sie noch kein teil der luxus sein ich
will mal in den statistiken dass
tatsächlich war 30 männer zuschauer kein
argument meines kanals sind und falls
sie schon am montag könnten auch auf die
glocke klicken
denn dann bekommt der benachrichtigung
sobald ich ein neues video hochladen ja
wahnsinn
ihr habt jetzt zeit unter dem video auf
abonnieren zu klicken oder auch die
glocke dann erfahrt ihr als erstes wenn
neues video kaufen können cool kommentar
schreiben hätte ich vielleicht top
kommend pizza kommt
november diesen jahres und ich bin ja
ich habe es mir jetzt auch
[Musik]